this is a level 83
pepper panic saga walkthrough video
I'm going to play the level and
complete it and try to walk you through
the thought processes. it is a difficult
level but by following our Pepper Panic Tips Pepper Panic Saga Level 83 guide you can beat it.
It is hard for a  couple reasons - there are only 15 moves
there's a very small four by four space
in the middle in which you have to
make matches to destroy the ice
and then get to this that in the stages
are all completely intact which
means they take 3 hits in the beginning we
can see we have green
blue and red trapped in the ice
and a sewer works like you want to make
the big matches first
to make direct the emerging group papers
if you can't get
the you wanna grow the colors that are
trapped in the ice its
you not gonna be able to totally break
them free that way or another years but
at least you can do something productive
whatever like right now I'd
harry gets actually have a pretty bad
senator because
all the colors are there
hearings in a way that I can use them so
much the screens on the outside drop
some new ones
their own is
this is pretty
free background with with her just to do
that an investor who this way
agreeable now it commits the road you
know the same poll released
clear some space you're not much in the
way of hell
but if you want all these things for on
the core you can see that you're making
a mess next to this actually brought
that went down so that we can make up
for
yes and missile just beat a
get this out of the way that's not want
to attract colors
%uh the help those be either way
actually
in ruins worth it this is what we're
looking for something like this before
government was going to hit the ice and
Corey Brewer
that paper
the yellow or also just the way so this
when you're going to make you mention
the millions China's look at where you
can
you make one more match to caretakers we
always
this is a
missiles to shock where the for the
school paper and hit this world
and now we have the blue set up or we
can we can start to panic and move her
to
the fastest way to do it
passes over be to make this match make
this man
make this man but I'd also like to clear
this Acer minutes the three
green purse and
and a little bit lucky here
from this since the all right now this
is a
this to you are actually this and get it
going
ill I don't know complete local
with her birth
well
for you
are the same with green yellow blue and
red to all the colours are trapped
so in that case you know I miss going to
make a move lower down over whenever I
don't have
the caramel for my sis yellow hero
mister ed
all good
romel to rehearsal
he week that the it's only a school
Matthews
this read more traffic during or agree
you know that's just to clear space more
than anything
here we have a choice thing for
24 paper matches one go to down go
inside
a I'd always pick the one going south
side
because this stuff here tends to clear
itself
we
you're using the truck with your
conservative was possible
to the grievance the for this long that
we don't have an angry mob
the in
it would be nice to set some up doing
three matches
you them
but they're really working
this is %uh this is a a strange but
because usually a five have to mention
really good thing if we we manage the
we're gonna 123 for the
was only a few go either yellow peppers
on the board
but we can
get anything else thing to do just to
clear the space more than anything
or it's a
you know that you see all the way I was
gonna now we have
for petrol and you see how much
different makes when I Cisco
you really your
you really the Acer you can make things
bigger matches
it's usually one of those things where
it's you can usually get
where the ice or you know start to panic
it's hard to get both or same really
have for
form
where he really meant reverses yellow
things that really only
a purple home we hit this morn
here it'll get us there
to move to the make this one stage by I
think this is our best match over here
at all
we'll get there on the stage for every
mister mister or side of the road I'm
pretty sure thanks for the yellow thing
that they're going
these wings and fly away from that
statue anyway so I will get their heads
or plus we are you a sedan natural
down there Michael stick with their plan
it was like it did a pretty good job
or a that's a pretty good outcome okay
so
let's look at the border we have if we
make this theory
here we will hit the statue with that
person former football star
another chain reaction yellow paper
here major Op
and hit both brother statues I'm not
sure
on a safe because these tumors drop at
the same time we'll see what happens see
that the other side
for but this will get a source that shit
anyways
so that's how you do it arm you know to
the couple tries its gonna
you know as there's no there's nothing
that I can tell you that's going to make
sure that you can get it every time you
know you're going to have to you
just make the best decisions on a
regular basis and
eventually work out